John Stamos and Caitlin McHugh are  expecting their first child have mercy  [Music]  the actors house is about to get a  little fuller 54 year old and his  fiancee revealed the happy news on  Wednesday on the cover of People  magazine the parents-to-be got engaged  in October at Disneyland after almost  two years of dating  just days after Stamos popped the  question he opened up to et about  wanting to start a family with his  leading lady I mean that's always been  you know my plan it's just taking me a  lot longer than I anticipated it would  be a tragedy if I didn't have children I  think and so I finally found the right  woman the perfect woman I know my my  parents are smiling down I know they  would love her she's a gentle kind  graceful soul that would be a good  [Music]  you